[The ball breaker]
Emil, did you bring some balls?
Yeah, they are on the floor!
Do you have any more balls?
I think this one is broken.
Yeah, it's broken!
Oops!
Sorry!
[The no backhand guy]
Maybe I should stick to playing forehand...
[The sweaty guy]
Good match!
[The lucky guy]
Sorry!
Always lucky.
It's all about skill!
[The tennis guy]
Ace!
This is not tennis!
[The excuses guy]
I can't see anything!
The lights... and the floor... and your shirt!
I just went to the gym yesterday, my hand is so stiff.
The table is not straight.
Now it's good!
My rubbers are too old!
There is not enough room here!
[The ritual guy]
[The diving guy]
Alright, so all of you who have not subscribed yet
Remember to do that now!
If you want to see a part 3 of stereotypes, give this video a thumbs a like.
Until next time!